[Music]
Yogesh you can - is executive director
of environmental action Germany will be
talking about the arrogance of the auto
companies the failure of politics and
the power his organization has welcomed
I'm sure hello luck your organization
has won a victory after a court gave
German cities to go ahead to impose
driving bans to curb air pollution this
even put you on the front page of the
New York Times how do you feel when you
take on big companies and the government
and win how long did you celebrate on
Tuesday there wasn't a lot of time for
celebration but I had a glass of wine
that evening alone in my favorite pub to
come down a bit it was a great day for
clean air in Germany we fought 13 years
for that we filed every possible legal
challenge and won them all but this was
confirmation that it applied to all
other cities you've had some successes
you started working for environmental
protection when you were still a student
you helped to introduce deposits on cans
and bottles in Germany but it's
Tuesday's decision your greatest success
I think it is I've been fighting for
clean air for three decades but I put it
up there with the introduction of
catalytic converters or my campaign 20
years ago to bring sulfur free fuels to
Germany and Europe both big steps but
let's just say that apart from the
publicity and the social impact this
victory of clean air over the interests
of the car companies has done just a bit
more but why was this Court ruling
necessary EU wide pollutants limits have
been in effect since 2010 but they
didn't apply in Germany they were only
on paper who was responsible for that it
then defined for them enough here this
is good notice that's the problem the
limits applied in Germany but obviously
politicians often don't implement laws
or regulations anymore especially if
they don't match the
interests of large industrial companies
the government starts behaving like a
common criminal it doesn't respect the
law
why have we won every single case for 13
years partly because we have good
lawyers but above all as we just said
it's the law we have a limit to be met
it prevents thousands of deaths the
courts have decided that this is true
but the government is violating this law
would they stop foresters buggy those
are strong words to accuse the
government of criminal behavior are you
saying that the German government puts
the interests of auto companies above
the common good yeah absolutely and I
can prove it
the automotive industry rules Germany
through the individual states and
through the chancellor's office Gerhard
schröder was a car makers Chancellor but
Angela Merkel has perfected that role
she is directly committed to automotive
interests in the EU and she told state
officials in California in 2010 that
they had to relax their emissions limits
saying they're bad for the German auto
industry but that's not her job she
should work for the good of the people
work if not the profit interests of a
small group of companies your close
friend and former colleague on
environmental protection matters is the
botton of it and back state premier then
freakish mom is he also in the auto
industry's pocket I'll go into solution
yeah yes even an honest green party
state premier faces this problem but I
still like him despite the
contradictions you're still close of
course I still like it man we get along
well but this situation demonstrates the
power of the automotive industry if a
state premier comes into office and says
fewer cars are better for the
environment and more cars you'll get
plenty of heat from the industry and
he'll soon behave like his predecessors
and that applies to the CSU the SPD and
all political parties in Germany the
industry has so much power and can also
play the jobs card with the politicians
as blackmail rinaldin Lewis Osgood oh
that's amiss the German car industry
generates a huge amount of revenue and a
lot of jobs depend on that industry but
let's take a look at the admissions
fraud scandal VW and the others treated
air pollution limits as a technical
hurdle that's just plain wrong are
lawmakers taking the right approach to
deal with these situations we drew a lot
of attention to this scam in 2007 and in
2011 we gave the German government
detailed information about VW's 189
engine which later became notorious in
the California case and how this engine
produced such different results on the
road compared to the lab where the
cheating took place but the politicians
weren't interested they wanted to help
the car industry our own executives told
them it was becoming more expensive to
meet emissions limits and asked them to
help by turning a blind eye and there
was obviously a gentlemen's agreement
here as long as you meet the test
standards we won't look at the road
results so despite our demands they
never did knock it off las casas how
about some but it often takes two sides
to commit fries the cheaters and those
who agree to be cheated for example
every driver knows that they'll never
come close to the fuel mileage listed on
the sticker what does that say about us
Germans is Environmental Protection
important only on paper and not such a
big deal in practice we have become a
bit complacent for years Germany has
been a leader in conservation and
Environmental Protection and we still
have that reputation abroad we've
convinced ourselves that were better
than a lot of others but the fact of the
matter is that on climate protection and
the co2 reduction we've made no progress
in recent years a lot of countries have
overtaken us in other areas too
and right now we're in the bottom third
of you members on all sorts of
environmental standards are we also a
bit fickle on Environmental Protection a
few years ago the diesel was considered
a clean engine but not anymore still
lots of people trusted those claims and
bought diesel cars toughness diseases
always disappointing occult I feel
swoosh but I think it's even worse than
that consumers are still quite concerned
about the environment and they simply
trusted the auto industry and the
authorities when they claimed that
diesels were clean and climate friendly
but there has been massive cheating in
Germany it's at least as extensive as
what we saw with nitrous oxide and
carbon dioxide numbers we've already
uncovered several cases of this cheating
such as how they faked lower fuel
consumption levels in tests this is
criminal behavior the German government
is looking into this for the first time
but it's not doing enough consumers
thought that the new diesels were
cleaner but when it comes to nitrogen
dioxides they're actually four to seven
times dirtier than a thirty-year old
diesel think about if you perceive mush
what cigars we provide see how easily so
and so millions of people who bought
diesel cars are now threatened with
driving bans and city centres 9 million
people have bought diesel cars that have
the latest certification they were told
that the cars were environmentally
friendly and city driving wouldn't be a
problem for a long time but what should
they do with their cars now they should
wait a few more days and hope that we
can reach an agreement with lawmakers
that would require the auto industry to
retrofit the engines or they could go to
their dealer and demand their money back
or a retrofit that would set a precedent
but that's now the job of politicians to
finally force the auto industry to do
this and they do have the means to do
this they can apply you law
and impose severe penalties for people
in Hamburg Hamburg will soon close the
first streets to dirty Diesel's the
people will just take other routes how
does that help the environment it what
because the courts have said that bypass
roads must also be blocked as soon as
people start using will be watching that
development very closely but it'll be
traffic chaos block off the whole city
that's why we were able to push through
a second option to ban Diesel's from the
environmental zone in Stuttgart the
entire city is an environmental zone
if Diesel's are kept out there's no more
bypass traffic this also has to be done
in Hamburg that's remarkable here you
are an environmental organisation and
you're suing the government to force it
to implement its own law office and
you've been doing that a long time and
you've been successful you seem to be on
a personal campaign for the environment
as a sort of white knight how do you see
yourself I've been doing this now for 35
years and I do it with enthusiasm and
great joy every day but I enjoy it most
when we don't have to go to court we try
to convince industry and increasingly
government officials through dialogue so
that they'll obey the law we shouldn't
have to demand that the police chase a
bank robber but what do you do when you
see the police robbing the bank who do
you call the state must enforce air and
water quality standards they can't stand
idly by and say there are targets that
we can't meet so we let 13,000 people
die every year four times more than in
traffic accidents and it's a trivial
offence in the u.s. VW executives are
behind bars for violating clean air
regulations but here they get medals in
famous Bowens becomes in winners for
these courts
adesh we're coming to the end of our
interview I'd like you to complete these
sentences my most beautiful car journey
was we can follow by a go no car her I
Drive a car but I really don't like to
if I prefer to go on bike tours around
Lake Constance with my electric bike and
you also like to take your solar boat
out on Lake Constance what's the best
thing about that I can relax and
contemplate the future I just wished
that in Germany we would further develop
this symbiosis between nature humanity
and culture and I'm now happy that we
can make a small contribution including
more livable cities other said that for
the future of my children I would most
like to see solving air and clean water
you're gonna fish thank you my pleasure